[Musik]
trauer und manfred stolpe brandenburgs
ehemaliger spd ministerpräsident stirbt
im alter von 83 jahren erster streiktag
bei germanwings flugbegleiter der
lufthansa tochter legen die arbeit
nieder
rund 60 flüge fallen aus die feier in
australien breiten sich weiter aus und
bedrohen jetzt auch vororte der
metropole melbourne
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen zu
den heute -nachrichten am 30 dezember
mit kristin otto für den sport und der
vierschanzentournee genannt er war der
erste ministerpräsident von brandenburg
nach der wiedervereinigung manfred
stolpe spd und trug dazu bei dass ost
und west zusammenwuchsen wie sich
politiker in berlin anlässlich seines
todes heute erinnern aber auch schon zu
ddr zeiten hatte er sich als mann der
kirche um ausgleich bemüht zwischen dem
regime und seinen gegnern
eben dies aber überschattete auch sein
wirken wird ihn erwarten und kathrin
antony darf man einer seiner letzten
öffentlichen auftritte
trotz schwerer krebserkrankung konnte im
vergangenen jahr zur ehrung für seinen
einsatz um die garnisonkirche in potsdam
heute wehen die flaggen vor der
staatskanzlei in potsdam auf halbmast
für mich war ja ein wegweiser umsetzung
politik von gerhard schröder im osten
das war eigentlich so der vater
brandenburg geboren wird er 1936 in
stettin engagiert sich früh in der
evangelischen kirche steigt auf in der
kirchenhierarchie mit besten kontakten
zur sed führung
er setzt sich für andersdenkende ein
kirche im sozialismus heißt für stolpe
platz für menschen die das system
verändern wollten als ministerpräsident
reicht ja so viel durchs land wie kaum
ein anderer politiker
sein schlüssel zum erfolg lautet
vermitteln und eiserne disziplin zu sich
selbst unter schlaf gutes gewissen und
jeden morgen doch sein gutes gewissen
wird jahrelang in frage gestellt stoiber
habe mit der stasi zusammengearbeitet
der verdacht konnte auch bei einem
untersuchungsausschuss nie belegt werden
aber es belastete ihn am letzten tag
seine zwölfjährigen regierungszeit hat
er tränen in den augen mit 66 jahren
ruft ihn noch einmal die pflicht er
tritt als bundesverkehrsminister an
zu seinem 75 geburtstag kommen sie alle
ob unterhaltungs profis oder politiker
er brachte alle zusammen diesen land auf
die beine geholfen ist war ein nicht
land bis 1989 ist selbst der begriff
brandenburg war bei niemandem mehr
präsent und durch manfred stolpe durch
sein wirken durch auch das was er an
kraft investiert hat ist dieses land
heimat geworden
manfred stolpe hat für brandenburg einen
schwierigen weg geebnet er war ein mann
und eine stimme aus dem osten die vielen
fehlen wird auch thüringens
ministerpräsident ramelow von der linken
reagierte mit trauer auf den tod stolpes
er habe die wiedervereinigung aktiv
mitgestaltet und brandenburg
vorangebracht
der bundesregierung warf ramelow das
interesse am osten vor
auf länder ebene funktioniere die
solidarität doch der bund behandle die
ostdeutschen länder wie die bucklige
verwandtschaft die ständig jammere sagte
er in einem interview mit dem redaktions
netzwerk
deutschland seit mitternacht läuft der
streik bei der lufthansa tochter
germanwings
dazu aufgerufen hat die gewerkschaft für
das kabinenpersonal ufo bisher sind rund
60 flüge ausgefallen
der ausstand soll bis einschließlich
mittwoch dauern
noch ist keine entspannung in sicht die
lufthansa und ufo sind weiter völlig
über kreuz
das heißt es drohen womöglich noch mehr
streiks heiko rams berichtet lange
schlangen an den check-in-schaltern am
flughafen köln bonn zahlreiche
germanwings flüge fallen heute aus
einige passagiere sind genervt bisschen
schwachsinn ich kann es verstehen wird
auch für mein geld strecken aber gerade
und zwischen den feiertagen ist ein
bisschen blöd also entscheidend wie ich
das verstanden habe ist ja nur um die
führungsebene die sie bisher unter druck
setzen wollen und dem zusammenhang finde
ich bisschen überzogen ich finde schon
okay wenn die leute da streiken
man kann sich darauf einrichten
besonders betroffen ist nordrhein
westfalen
vor allem inlandsverbindungen vom
flughafen köln bonn am wochenende
verhandelten arbeitgeber und
gewerkschaft unter anderem über
teilzeitmodelle für arbeitnehmer doch es
kam trotz langer verhandlungen zu keiner
lösung
wir waren es die eine schlichtung
allerdings verlief themen angeboten
haben die uv c abgelehnt und wir waren
es die jetzt gestern oder vorgestern das
beste modell für teil zeitler anbieten
das ist in der luftfahrtindustrie gibt
doch das modell sei für die
beschäftigten von germanwings nicht
passend argumentiert die gewerkschaft
sei vor allem auf langstreckenflüge
ausgerichtet während germanwings
überwiegend kurz und
mittelstreckenflieger das seien ganz
andere arbeitszeiten
das was wir wieder für die germanwings
brauchen ist etwas völlig anderes und
insofern mag das nicht klingen aber es
hat leider gar nichts mit dem zu tun
dass wir gefordert hatten
die gewerkschaft droht den streik über
neujahr hinaus zu verlängern wenn es zu
keiner einigung kommt keine guten
aussichten für die passagiere
mit dem jahreswechsel treten einige
gesetzesänderungen in kraft dadurch
können 2020 manche mit mehr geld im
portemonnaie rechnen es drohen aber auch
empfindliche strafen etwa bei
verkehrsvergehen die wichtigsten
neuerungen hat für uns dominik
löschmeister zusammengetragen
mindestlohn er steigt zum ersten januar
von aktuell 9 9 10 auf 9 euro 35 die
stunde
auszubildende bekommen ab 2020 erstmals
eine mindestvergütung von mindestens 515
euro im ersten lehrjahr wohngeld die
bundesregierung will haushalte mit
geringem einkommen entlasten das
wohngeld wird ab januar an die miet- und
einkommensentwicklung angepasst für
einen zwei-personen-haushalt steigt die
leistung im schnitt von 145 auf 190 euro
im monat klimapaket bahnfahren wird ab
2020 billiger die mehrwertsteuer auf
bahntickets sinkt von 19 auf 7 prozent
die luftverkehrssteuer steigt dagegen
zum ersten april zb für europäische
ziele von 7 euro 50 auf 13 eur 3
arzttermine patienten der reichen ab
januar rund um die uhr sieben tage die
woche die termine service stelle unter
der telefonnummer 116 117 werden dann
neben fachärzten auch hausärzte
vermittelt straßenverkehr
das bußgeld für parken auf geh und
radwegen steigt
von 20 auf 55 euro wer keine
rettungsgasse bildet so künftig auch mit
einem monat fahrverbot bestraft werden
mit dem einsatz von quereinsteigern an
schulen versuchen viele länder dem
lehrermangel zu begegnen
sehr zum ärger des lehrerverbandes der
präsident der vereinigung meidinger
kritisierte in der zeitung die welt
vielerorts würden pädagogische leyen auf
schüler losgelassen das sei ein
verbrechen an den kindern
widerspruch gab es vom präsidenten der
kultusministerkonferenz lords einige
länder kämen nicht ohne quereinsteiger
aus sie würden aber gezielt fortgebildet
ins ausland die usa sind mit mehreren
luftangriffen gegen schiitische milizen
in syrien und im irak vorgegangen
mindestens 25 kämpfer sollen dabei
getötet worden sein
mit den militärschlägen reagiert
washington auf einen raketenangriff im
irak vor drei tagen bei dem ein us
bürger ums leben kam
dafür macht washington die dortigen
hisbollah brigaden verantwortlich die
drohten nun mit vergeltung die milizen
werden von iran unterstützt nach
australien wo sich die buschbrände immer
weiter ausbreiten
am wochenende stiegen die temperaturen
örtlich wieder über 40 grad und noch
immer fehlt der ersehnte regen während
bislang vor allem die region rund um die
metropole sydney betroffen war gerät nun
auch der äußerste süden des kontinents
in gefahr
zehntausende bewohner der vororte von
melbourne wurden aufgerufen sich in
sicherheit zu bringen
florian gottschick berichtet das feuer
hat pandora erreicht ein vorort von
melbourne
unermüdlich versuchen die einsatzkräfte
häuser vor den flammen zu schützen noch
gelingt es ihnen doch das feuer ist
weiterhin außer kontrolle
an verschiedenen stellen frisst es sich
die hügel hinab vielen bleibt nur noch
die flucht
wir haben uns in sicherheit gebracht und
nun müssen wir sehen wie sich alles
entwickelt nun wir haben familie und
wenn irgendetwas passiert könnten wir
hier festsitzen und das können wir nicht
riskieren
der katastrophenschutz warnt wer bleibt
dem droht gefahr von den flammen
eingeschlossen zu werden denn etliche
straßen sind nicht mehr befahrbar
dank hitze starker winde und der
extremen dürre haben die brände leichtes
spiel
in einigen regionen sind sie so
übermächtig dass hunderte feuerwehrleute
abgezogen werden müssen
zu gefährlich ist die lage eine fläche
größer als belgien ist schon verbrannt
mehr als 1000 häuser sind zerstört
australiens hauptstadt canberra hat
deshalb das silvesterfeuerwerk abgesagt
anders als sydney
dort sollen um mitternacht wieder
raketen über brücke und opernhaus
fliegen obwohl mehr als eine viertel
million bürger eine petition
unterschrieben haben für eine absage ihr
anliegen spenden stadt spektakel
das geld solle lieber an opfer und
helfer der brände gehen und genug qualm
liegt ohnehin schon in der luft auch
ganz ohne feuerwerk zurück nach
deutschland da hat der deutsche
wetterdienst eine erste bilanz für das
jahr 2009 10 gezogen
demnach war es eines der wärmsten jahre
seit beginn der aufzeichnungen 1881 mit
einem neuen temperaturrekord 42,6 grad
celsius gemessen in lingen im emsland
ein extrem heißer sommer und fast
überall deutlich zu trocken
die folge eine langanhaltende dürre
macht äckern und wäldern schwer zu
schaffen
andrea meuser mit dem rückblick schnee
und hitze starkregen und dürre 2009 10
war ein jahr der wetter extreme und mit
zwei hitzewellen braucht der sommer alle
temperaturrekorde wir hatten ende juni
eine erste phase mit temperaturen in der
letzten woche juli-woche von mehr als 35
grad wir hatten in der letzten juliwoche
sogar eine phase mit temperaturen an
drei aufeinanderfolgenden tagen von mehr
als 40 grad das gab es noch nie seit wer
regelmäßig wetter messen
kein wunder also dass es vor allem die
hitze ist von der die menschen sprechen
wenn man sie nach ihren wetter
erinnerungen 2009/10 fragt im sommer
natürlich wie jeder schon war es wieder
ein stück zu trocken ab und zu mal war
die wetter sehr viel zu heiß für uns er
musste viel was er auf dem garten
versprechen und zusagen und problem in
zukunft für uns und nicht nur der sommer
war warm die wetterdaten zeigen in jedem
monat außerdem mai lagen die
temperaturen in deutschland über dem
langjährigen durchschnitt und mit der
hitze kam die dürre
da haben auch die starken regenfälle der
letzten wochen nicht viel geholfen
wir haben es ja noch viel zu trocken in
den großen tiefen und das kann das
nächste problem im nächsten jahr sein
also es muss regnen jetzt in den
nächsten monaten im frühjahr oder wir
brauchen ein insgesamt verregneten
sommer damit überhaupt diese dürre im
unterboden aufgefüllt wird die
landwirtschaft der wald und die menschen
alle haben gelitten in diesem jahr 2019
dem dritt wärmsten seit beginn der
wetteraufzeichnungen
die deutsche wirtschaft hat ein
turbulentes jahr hinter sich themen wie
importzölle brh exit oder
elektromobilität haben ihre spuren
hinterlassen
an den aktienkursen lässt sich das
allerdings kaum ablesen denn da sind
viele werte nach wie vor auf rekordjagd
wie das zusammenpasst zeigt der
rückblick auf das abgelaufene börsenjahr
isabel de la vega sektlaune an der
frankfurter börse
es war ein gutes jahr 2019 ging der dax
ordentlich nach oben
hersteller von konsumgütern wie zum
beispiel adidas und jene die sie zum
kunden transportieren wie die deutsche
post gehören zu den gewinnern des jahres
bei den deutschen klassikern dem
maschinenbau und der automobilindustrie
allerdings stotterte der motor
wir haben branchen- die haben 20 19
federn gelassen das ist klar dass es zum
beispiel die automobilindustrie das sind
die energieversorger das ist der
maschinenbau hier wirken sich vor allen
dingen die hohen energiepreise aus aber
eben auch der umbruch in der
automobilindustrie hat ordentliche
bremsspuren in der bilanz hinterlassen
wir haben aber auf der anderen seite auf
branchen- gehabt die gut registriert
haben der konsum läuft beispielsweise
sehr gut nach wie vor haben die leute
viel geld in daran geht
ist billig weil die ezb ihre
niedrigzinspolitik fortsetzte das hat im
endeffekt zu einer suche nach rendite
geführt das hat zu einer höheren
risikobereitschaft der anlegerinnen und
anleger geführt so dass am ende die
nachfrage nach höher verzinslichen
wertpapieren gestiegen ist und damit die
aktienkurse gestiegen sind und wie
wirkten sich trump und die
handelskonflikte am ende auf die börse
aus überraschung die amerikaner haben
sogar ihre importe aus deutschland in
den letzten quartalen gesteigert also
einen trump knick oder so etwas kann man
in der deutschen außenhandel statistik
nicht feststellen und deswegen ist auch
nicht verwunderlich dass das die börsen
nicht so stark getrieben hat viel
wichtiger sei für die börse die
geldpolitik der ezb gewesen und die wird
sich auch 2020 kaum ändern
für viele gehört zum jahresausklang auch
unbedingt ein gutes konzert dresden
freut sich in diesem jahr auf höhepunkte
aus einem operetten klassiker franz
lehárs land des lächelns einer innigen
begegnung von west und fernost ohne
glückliches ende
heimspiel für eines der führenden
orchester der welt der sächsischen
staatskapelle
bei der generalprobe in der semperoper
war thomas bärsch dabei
dein ist mein ganzes herz wo du nicht
bist kann ich nicht sein wer kennt es
nicht
franz lehár bietet in seiner operette
das land des lächelns kein happy end
was macht sie denn noch silvesterkonzert
tauglich na ja dass man ein bisschen
nachdenklich ins neue jahr sich eine
merkwürdige kombination von schlagern ja
eigentlich ist jede nummer mehr oder
minder eigentlich auch einem breiteren
publikum bekannt schon mal gehört
manchmal weiß man gar nicht dass das
land des lächelns ist also man trifft
alte bekannte wieder er eben und am
schluss geht es mal nicht so gut aus die
proben noch ohne kostüm im land des
lächelns folgt eine wiener grafentochter
ihrer liebe nach china doch der brauch
verlangt das prinzip schon dort gleich
vier mann show mädchen heiratet
letztlich muss der prinz seine leser mit
traurigem lächeln ziehen lassen
die operette lebt vom orchester und vom
spiel der liebenden geführt an
unsichtbaren fäden des dirigenten mit
ihm ist es ein spaß weil er hängt an den
lippen und er hängt an dem sänger und
ich habe sänger muss ich dann keine
schwierigkeiten oder keine sorgen haben
dass engagiert sind die zu zu laut oder
zu langsam
weil wir machen das so zusammen dass das
klappt jede note oder jede so
verzierungen und so diese was eigentlich
spaß bei der operette haben machen das
land des lächelns morgen nachmittag 17
uhr 25 in der semperoper dresden und
hier im zdf ja und jetzt hier im zdf zum
sport und da gibt es große freude bei
den skispringern absolut zurecht teil
eines gut geglückt karl geiger hat
diesmal dem druck standgehalten als
lokalmatador und mit-favorit platz zwei
im hexenkessel von oberstdorf ein
überaus verheißungsvolle einstieg in die
vierschanzentournee
es war die pure freude endlich war der
erfolg da zu hause in oberstdorf wo sich
keine geige doch immer so schwer getan
hat platz zwei nach sprüngen auf 135 und
134 meter wieder ist ein deutscher vorn
dabei im rennen um den tourneesieg nur
er war wieder nicht zu schlagen rio
kobayashi der japaner gewann sein
fünftes toni springen nacheinander
springen schon gut aber seine waren
wirklich unfassbar feine klinge das hat
man auch gesehen wurde er wurde
wegspringen ist aber du mir werden denn
weiter ärgern und in garmisch gibt es
eine neue chance
garmisch partenkirchen die nächste
station nur nicht für richard freitag
nach dem aus in der qualifikation ist
die tournee für ihn vorzeitig beendet
das ist auch gut so einfach mal wieder
auf reset zu stellen das ganze und und
einfach mal wieder mal durchzuschnaufen
abzuschalten und die zeiten wollen wir
ihnen jetzt geben für karl geiger aber
scheint alles möglich fünf meter trennen
ihn von dem tournee- führenden kobayashi
ja noch drei stationen und die quali in
garmisch partenkirchen gibt es morgen
live in zdf sportextra viertel vor zwei
gerade mal sieben tage pause gönnte
herthas trainer jürgen klinsmann seinen
spielern nun ging es wieder los mit der
vorbereitung auf die bundesliga
rückrunde
als tabellenzwölfter stecke man nach wie
vor im abstiegsstrudel und deswegen
müsse man früher ran und ein bisschen
mehr tun
und anders als in der bundesliga gibt es
in der premier league traditionell keine
winterpause erfreulich für jürgen klopp
und den fc liverpool die erfolgsserie
der reds setzt sich zwar auch zum
jahresabschluss vor siege wie der gegen
wurde händen lassen liverpool in dieser
premier league-saison einsame spiel zu
sein
wenig glanz dennoch drei punkte im
letzten spiel des jahres für das team
von jürgen klopp
du musst mit allem bekämpfen was du hast
mal hast du mehr mal weniger die jungs
tun das immer ich könnte also nicht
stolzer sein dass sie es wieder
geschafft haben
man erzielte kurz vor der pause das 1 0
das der schiedsrichter zunächst wegen
vermeintlichen handspiels des
vorbereiters leeraner aberkannt hatte
doch der video assistent revidierte die
entscheidung die führung für die reds
erst in den schlussminuten riskierten
die gäste mehr kamen aber nicht zum
ausgleich liverpool nach exakt der
hälfte der saison nun mit 13 punkten
vorsprung auf den zweiten letzter bei
einem spiel weniger
das ziel bleibt natürlich der erste
titel für liverpool seit 30 jahren
gespart werden
danke fürs team zum wetter über den
mittelgebirgen kann es morgen etwas
regnen
zu den einzelheiten gleich mehr von
gunther tiersch das heute journal mit
claus kleber um 21 uhr 45 wir danken für
ihr interesse und wünschen noch einen
gemütlichen abend bis morgen
[Musik]
namentliche zuschauer morgen wird es
nicht mehr so sonnig wie heute und es
wird sogar noch etwas milder werden
da befinden wir uns in guter
gesellschaft in europa meist sind die
temperaturen liegen zwischen fünf und
zehn im südwesten bis zu 15 grad wo es
winter vielleicht gerade auf dem balkan
oder auch ganz im norden und bei uns
natürlich gibt es den frost in der nacht
in der mitte und im süden wieder bis
minus 7 grad nach norden bleibt es
frostfrei und hier ziehen im laufe der
nacht wolken heran
die bringen in der zweiten nachthälfte
auch etwas regen sonst bleibt es klar
mit dem nebel am oberrhein seit zwei
tagen da kommt ja gar nicht mehr raus
und tagsüber haben wir dieses wolkenband
das von norton heranzieht über der mitte
liegen
es kann am thüringer wald sauerland aber
auch im erzgebirge etwas regnen
zumindest am vormittag ist der boden
noch gefroren wird es natürlich glatt
und im norden weht ein kräftiger
nordwestwind dazu da ist es sonnig das
bleibt auch nachmittags so nachmittags
gibt es kein regen und am späten
nachmittag abend erreicht dieses folgen
band auch die alten die temperaturen
steigen noch etwas an sechs bis neun
grad sind es im größten teil
deutschlands nur in teilen
süddeutschlands bleibt es kühler mit
zwei bis vier grad in der silvesternacht
wird es kalt und sternenklaren neuer
dann teilweise neblig teilweise auch
sonnig und erst am freitag erwarten wir
von nordwesten neuen regen ich wünsche
ihnen einen schönen abend und machen sie
es gut